all right spider-man no way home spoiler
review i am going to be talking about
spoilers in this video i know a lot of
people have been waiting for this so if
you have not seen spider-man no way home
and you don't want to know anything
about it i'll give you a few seconds to
leave until we really get into it
they did it
they did it they made a spider verse
film with the three spider-mans it's
insane i cannot believe that they
actually did this yes we've been talking
about it for a while yes i was talking
about the three spider-man showing up
for over a year now but to see it on
film was spectacular and it's not just
the fact that we saw it on film that
makes me love it so much it's not just
the fact that we saw them there it's how
they did it they actually executed this
in my opinion
perfectly i think they did it exactly
the way they needed to do it yes there
was some fan service in there but i
think they did it incredibly well and i
think everything else that came along
with the movie was just spectacular and
i'm going to talk about why i think this
is the greatest superhero movie of all
time now right off the bat i acknowledge
that not everybody is going to think
that i personally am a little bit biased
towards spider-man if you haven't been
able to tell over the past year or so i
love spider-man he's fantastic but this
story in particular really took it over
the top for me and this is the
spider-man end game that's what they've
been calling it and that's what we kind
of knew with the all the spider-man
coming together but it's not just the
spider-man coming together that makes
this movie truly awesome this is
actually a peter parker story
and tom holland gets his peter parker
story i mean you know toby and andrew
are only in what the last
45 minutes 30 minutes um and i'm glad
they did it that way and i'm glad they
came in the way they came in i'm glad
they just didn't start swinging in and
fighting i actually preferred the
science bros parts which i'm i'm gonna
say that that's what that part is called
i i loved how they did that but let's
start off
with just tom holland because this is
his movie right yes it's this huge
in-game movie but this is his movie and
his uh acting really
tom wow uh i don't i'm not sure i've
seen this from him before i definitely
haven't seen it from him with his past
spider-man movie uh i like tom holland
as spider-man toby maguire's always been
my favorite but tom hall i think stepped
it up in this one i i really do the
story was really good the emotion that
came with it
wow what a roller coaster of emotion you
know i'm going to talk about that in
detail but tom i feel like this was his
time to shine and he he performed he
shined he really did i think he gave it
his all and if it comes through on the
screen tom if you happen to stumble upon
this video thank you for this movie
because i i can see that you you truly
put your all into it i
you made me cry you made me laugh
um it tom was phenomenal it's almost
phenomenal and speaking of acting the
villains oh my gosh i didn't think
willem dafoe could do better than he did
as the green goblin in the first
spider-man film but wow was he
terrifying
in this movie terrifying in this movie
menacing i mean it was just it was it
was perfect i didn't think it
i didn't think it could get better and
it did willem the foe just came back
after like 20 years and was like let me
show you how it's done it's almost like
he was thinking about this role for the
past 20 years and was like well i could
do it like this and then he finally gets
his chance he's like watch me do it
perfectly and he did it perfectly now
the other villains of course they showed
up as well because you have actors like
alfred molina
and jamie foxx and they're just
fantastic as well and everything that
involved them was executed perfectly
again i loved jamie foxx's character i
loved how confident he was i loved kind
of the new new as he calls it that was
pretty great the only thing about some
of the other villains is like sandman
and the lizard they were they were just
kind of there right they were just kind
of there in the background but they did
have their moments right same man pops
up and he helps peter he's like peter
it's me flint right and he tries to save
him and he gets confused because peter's
like i'm better but now you're peter's
like what and so he helps him and then
he kind of turns because he doesn't
trust him right he had his time to shine
as well i think and then of course you
have the lizard who
basically i just think all of the
villains in this movie and basically all
the returning characters did a
phenomenal job i think we actually saw
the villains in a better light than
we've ever seen them though i think they
did
i think they all did better than they
did in their films actually so which is
hard to say
it's hard to say because up for melina
did fantastic willem dafoe they all did
fantastic in the movies that they
originally came out on but this was just
this i feel like was on a whole nother
level but let's talk about
how they brought the spidermans in
because that to me
was the best part now ned finds out that
he's magic and can open a portal which
is kind of a qualm i have because it
seems like he did it just a little bit
too easy but it's not a movie about ned
so i don't really care that much right
um i think the way they did everything
else completely just trumps the little
tiny things that maybe you could have
changed so i don't really nitpick at
that right now but now it opens up a
portal right and he says i just want to
see peter and then we see the other
spiderman it's a silhouette of andrew
garfield's spider-man in the background
and they're like come come come and he
comes in and we you could tell by the
suit the fans already knew by the suit
and then he takes the mask off and
there's the werewolf right in your face
and the banter is funny right he's like
prove that you're spider-man do you have
the spider tingle i do but not for bread
being thrown at me and then we have
ned's mom asking him to clean the spider
webs and then toby shows up he tries to
do it again toby shows up and it's just
perfect and the two of them fight for
like two seconds and i was like i kind
of wanted something like a little bit
more than that but i didn't really want
him to fight but once i saw i'm like oh
my gosh they're about to fight this is
actually going to be crazy cool and they
did for like two seconds and i actually
thoroughly enjoyed that but it was
perfect because then they stepped in as
uncle ben
because that's what we wanted right
because for tom for tom spider-man in
this movie we had like a reverse uncle
ben
right aunt may became uncle ben because
normally it's uncle ben that dies right
and says with great power comes great
responsibility and then when he dies
peter parker is left with aunt may
however
this is kind of the opposite now we
don't really know what happened to uncle
ben we could probably assume that tom
holland's uncle ben died but aunt may
took that role in this movie she gave
him that line with great power comes
great responsibility and then she dies
but now peter has nobody
that's when toby and andrew show up and
they kind of take that role of uncle ben
they kind of are there to console him
and they hug him and it's like the
dynamic between the three of them is
simply amazing so they come in
and they all just connect perfectly and
i'm going to talk about my favorite part
of the movie right now because it starts
right in the scene where they start
talking to peter andrew garfield
no really like
andrew garfield i think brought so much
to this movie and his character made me
cry
his character made me cry for those
people who wanted redemption for andrew
garfield spider-man i feel like they
really got it i feel like andrew himself
got whatever he was looking for from
this movie because obviously it was
really really hard for him right not a
lot of people liked his movies that's
not really on him i think he was a
really good spider-man the movies
weren't cut out to be
what they were supposed to be right
that's not on him but this movie oh my
gosh whenever he would talk about gwen
and when he saved mj and he landed and
he was crying i cried like i cried and i
just saw it again last night i still
cried whenever he'd be talking about
gwen i i
it was really really emotional really
emotional and then we had the part where
he's talking to toby and he's like i
suck and toby's like wait a second
you're amazing now this part i love
because it's like meta right it's
obviously like oh he's the amazing
spider-man right that's really clever
but i feel like this is also like a
conversation that he's had maybe with
toby but definitely had like on his own
like wow toby maguire spider-man has
loved tom holland spider-man's is loved
but i'm kind of not right people don't
really like
my movies and this is where you know
they're kind of saying like no you are
amazing you're amazing and he's like i'm
not gonna lie i needed that
i really enjoyed that because i feel
like it was addressing like kind of him
how he probably feels because not a lot
of people love his movies too much and
he was supposed to get that third film
and that got cancelled because well they
needed to bring spidey into the mcu but
this was redemption for andrew garfield
i feel
not that he himself needed it because
again i don't think he did a bad job of
spiderman but this was perfect for me
this was absolutely perfect for me and
toby toby's my favorite and i think he
came in and he played the part that he
was supposed to play perfectly you know
he's the older spider-man we got the
callbacks like my back my back and he's
there like all right about to start he
like starts stretching and the two of
them are like oh yeah i got my back
problem yeah yeah you want me to pop
your back and um
i love it and then at the end it when
he's when he steps in front
of tom holland's peter parker to stop
him from killing the goblin
that's him being an older spider-man who
knows what spider-man and peter parker
are all about they are not about killing
they are about curing as tobey mcguire
says and we get that part
when the science bros are all you know
trying to get the cures for everything
and he goes i think i can cure osbourne
and if you notice
you look at tom holland's spider-man he
kind of looks down and kind of looks at
him because osborne just killed aunt may
but then toby looks at him and he goes
we gotta cure all of them right that's
what we do
and that's the role that toby maguire's
peter parker plays the older more mature
more experienced peter parker the one
that has a wife now right that has mj we
can assume because he's a lot older you
know he says they made it work which was
really really cool as well to hear them
all talk about you know
girls you know what happened with theirs
poor andrew but he steps in and then he
gets stabbed and that moment oh my gosh
at that moment
i was about to be really really mad
because i in my mind going into the
movie i was like there's zero reasons
for you to kill toby mcguire spider-man
there's zero reasons for you to pull a
guy out of his own universe who's very
very happy who we all love bring him
into ours and kill him for no reason but
he got stabbed
but he lived so that was like that was
phenomenal right another aspect of the
movie that i liked was the doctor
strange aspect
because it kind of like you you made it
because it kind of connected it right to
the mcu but it didn't deter too much we
had some really really cool fight scenes
um we saw how smart peter parker was
during those scenes and what that did
was set up peter parker to kind of be on
his own
with his two best friends mj and ned and
i feel like
this movie really did give tom holland's
peter parker time to shine like i
mentioned before but the best part about
this movie i think is that it showed us
and it really did capture
who peter parker is who spider-man is
on the inside and with the help of aunt
may he realizes that
he's supposed to help people
that's what spider-man does the friendly
neighborhood spider-man and this is
really demonstrated throughout the film
even as he goes through i'll call his
torture of having lost out man wanting
his revenge on green goblin
at the end of the movie
you have the two people that he loves
the most he lost aunt may
they're all he has
he makes the promise that he's gonna
show up again and tell them
i love you hey this is what happened and
then like click maybe everything's gonna
come back and he goes and he meets mj
and he sees that they both got into mit
he sees that their lives are better
and he questions telling them
but then it looks like he still decides
that he's going to right because maybe
me telling them
when it changed something is probably
what he's thinking in his head but then
she moves her hair back and he sees the
bandage on her head and he realizes that
came from me
right she's in danger because of me and
as long as i'm spider-man she's always
gonna be in danger and that's like the
big spider-man thing right as long as
i'm spider-man you're always in danger
so what does he decide to do
he himself
makes the sacrifice
for the better good of the people he
loves
and that to me is what spider-man is all
about and again that's a tom holland
spider-man right there right yeah the
other two came in and it was phenomenal
and i loved every second of it but this
is what spider-man is about even you
know when he goes to doctor strange it
says do it make everyone forget me
because that'll save the universe it's
for the greater good spider-man puts
other people in front of him that's who
spider-man is and that was captured in
this movie i feel with tom hall and
spider-man same thing with the other
spider-man's thing same thing with toby
stepping up and keeping him from killing
green goblin that was two-fold right
that was to keep tom's spider-man from
going down a dark path which clearly the
other two have and it was to save
osborne who was sick right he knew he
was sick it's not him it was the goblin
now of course i have to mention the
hand-to-hand comeback because speaking
of tom and the goblin wow what a final
scene that was when they were fighting
and we got to see tom just in full rage
mode using his webs to fight using his
physical power to fight and the way he
like slinged him on the floor amazing
then not to mention when they're
fighting in the apartment building
i mean goblins like throwing him through
walls slamming him through like multiple
levels of the building going down
absolutely beating the crap out of him
and you know if aunt may wasn't there
goblin would have killed him but
fortunately and unfortunately
mae was there and that ended up killing
her and we had the you know the uncle
ben moment which was necessary for
spider-man right
was necessary but the action was insane
even when he's fighting doc ock with the
tentacles that was fantastic i loved how
that happened he's picking up cars he's
picking up you know those huge concrete
like cylinder things and he's throwing
at him and he's actually getting hit and
he's actually kind of getting beat up
and it's it's actually really really
cool i thought the action was phenomenal
then you get the three spider-man and
they're kind of a mess at first right
because they're used to working alone
and then we get that cool thing with tom
hall tomorrow and spider-man's like i
was an avenger and toby's like you
weren't avenger that's great what's an
avenger like it cracked me up even in
the midst of like all the serious stuff
they still manage to keep that humor
which i personally love i know some
people are like oh the humor is still
too much now i really like it i feel
like spider-man is that type of
character
so i just feel like they did a lot of
justice to the character but then of
course
they come together and it's tom that
brings them together which is what i
really like because it's still about him
right tom who is the youngest spider-man
and i would argue you know hasn't
matured the most as the others just
because he's younger says you know we're
going to work as a team we're gonna
trust each other we're gonna trust our
tingle let's go do this and then the
next sequence is just the best thing
i've ever seen in my life three
spider-man swinging together landing
down together which by the way we all
knew that that was cut out of the out of
the trailers right i mean that was
pretty obvious and then you know then we
do have the spider-man kicking the
lizard in the face obviously right i
mean that was pretty great but
that next sequence of the spider-man
working together of one of the i think
it was tom spider-man that swings up
shoots the other two spider-man webs
them up and they all swing together i
mean they just and you know they they
did everything i wanted them to do with
the spider-man's like they did the
pointy meme right and they did it in a
way that was different right they're
like hey peter it's like yeah oh you
just talking to you so they're trying to
talk to me that was perfect i love that
take on it they talked about the organic
web shooters versus the you know
mechanized web shooters that was so
perfect and they actually made like kind
of like a run it on joke about it right
they're like whoa well how does that
even and andrew's like so confusing and
then they get on you know statue of
liberty and they're like so like is it
just your wrist or is it coming out of
anywhere else like they did exactly
what i feel like if this was all real
would happen right it's like no we're
not teasing you we just have to make
ours and you just produce yours and then
talk about you know did you ever have a
web block and he's like oh yeah i did
you know we've all seen that movie where
he can't and he's like why it's like
existential crisis and it's just like
they did everything perfectly i feel
like they really did do everything
perfectly
for this movie they brought in the three
spider-mans
and they did fan service to us but it
all made sense and that is truly why i
love this movie because they gave us
something we've always wanted
and it made sense they executed it
perfectly and then you take the cast
this grade a cast and they had everyone
perform
to the best level that they could which
i truly believe i think everybody gave
it their all i think the acting was
phenomenal and then they threw in some
really great action sequences and then
they took you on an emotional roller
coaster pulling at your heart strings
mae dying toby getting stabbed peter
parker crying andrew garfield crying
about gwen and then saving mj and then
crying about that they i think they did
everything perfectly and that's why i
think i think it's the perfect
spider-man movie i think it's the
perfect superhero movie and it's not my
favorite movie of all time i
it is and call me but it's really liking
spider-man so much that's fine i totally
get it and like i said some people are
gonna say it's a great movie not my
favorite that's fine that's fine but
this is my review and i just told you
why i why i think so because i think it
it really captured
tom spiderman i think it gave him his
time to shine it was emotional
journey for sure and the villains were
fainted like honestly the movie would
have been fantastic if it was just tom
versus all the other villains because
that was executed perfectly
and then you just but you had the other
three everything we've talked about
over
the years
we had
i mean like everything daredevil showed
up in the beginning like um
it's insane so
this is now my new favorite movie this
is my review on spiderman home hope you
all loved it i hope everybody watching
this has already watched the film
because you want to go into this
as you all will know not you know having
the least amount of boys as you can it's
like yeah i've been talking about toby
and andrew showing up for years right
for for over a year
but there was always like that point
zero zero zero one percent in the back
of my head going like well you know it
never was confirmed by sony yet so we'll
see 99.99 nine percent of me knew right
i talked to people i know insiders blah
blah blah blah but there was that point
zero zero zero zero one percent that was
like
we'll see and that actually made me love
the movie more going in
not knowing when they were going to show
up and going like show up show up show
up and they showed up and it was just it
was fantastic so
i hope you love the movie now my new
favorite movie thank you for joining me
on this journey if you didn't catch my
thank you video i did it yesterday
thanking all of you for supporting me
over the time and now we have some crazy
stuff coming up obviously we're going to
be talking about spider-man more but
multiverse of madness is coming up
king's coming in ant-man there's just so
much thorough love and thunder guardians
three we're not done this is only part
of the journey and it's only going to
get better for here but in the meantime
let me know what you thought about the
movie rate it in the comments down below
i am curious to hear everyone's opinion
on this i love you all 3000 and i will
catch you all next time woof
you